bonjour et bienvenue pour cette foire
aux questions stop science aujourd'hui
consacré à la question nous aurait-on
menti
lucie serait elle un babouin la nouvelle
est tombée comme un coup de tonnerre sur
la communauté paléontologique le 6 juin
dans un article publié dans la revue
journal of human evolution un fragment
de vertèbre de l'uci le plus fameux des
australopithèques appartiendrait en fait
à un babouin les implications de cette
découverte sont lourdes
si ça se trouve à l 280 8-1 plus connu
sous le petit sobriquet de l'uci ne
serait pas faite d'un seul et unique
squelette mais d'au moins 2 et si ça se
trouve de même plusieurs autres
fragments de squelettes et peut-être
même pas de la même espèce
comment une vertèbre de babouins at elle
pu se retrouver là au milieu du
squelette de lucy et surtout comment at
elle pu y rester aussi longtemps
une quarantaine d'années sans que
personne ne s'en rende compte les
implications de la réponse à cette
question vont nous emmener à travers
d'autres questions auxquelles nous
allons répondre à travers cette vidéo
notamment d'une part donc comment sept
vertèbres de babouins at elle pu arriver
là comment les scientifiques ont ils pu
être dupées pendant toutes ces années
la théorie de l'évolution se
trouve-t-elle menacée et que faire pour
remplacer l'uci dans le futur
commençons d'abord par tâcher de
comprendre comment une vertèbre de
babouins at elle pu se retrouver dans le
squelette de lucy a simplement quand on
parle du squelette de lucy on ne parle
pas d'un fossile qui a été trouvé dans
une fouille conventionnelles en tout cas
pas en entier parce que j'appelle une
fouille conventionnelle c'est en gros on
creuse un trou et à l'intérieur du trou
on trouve un squelette tout articulé
tout entier et on décrète que ce
squelette appartient à une seule et
unique personne ce qui semble
raisonnable
l'uci n'a pas été découvertes comme ça
les premiers fragments de l'uci ont été
ramassés directement surface glané au
pied d'un talus dans lequel se trouvait
le reste du squelette dans les années 70
quand les paléontologues explorer
l'afrique de l'est à la recherche de
fossiles et bien un jour ils sont tombés
sur un fragment de d'avant-bras un
radius qui s'est rapidement trouvé
accompagné d'un fragment de crâne un os
occipital et puis dans les alentours ils
ont découvert un fémur des côtes
un fragment de bassins et même une
mâchoire inférieure remontant la piste
de tous et au dispersés ils ont fini par
découvrir une couche géologique
très riche en ossements et qui leur a
livré tout le reste d'un squelette
complet à 40% d'hominidés que nous
connaissons maintenant sous le nom de
lucie à l'époque ils ont on va dire
assumer que tous les os venait du même
squelette donc du squelette de
l'individu nommé l'uci parce que ils
n'ont trouvé aucun doublon qui vous
voulez dans la couche riche en ossements
en fossiles il y avait des fossiles
d'autres animaux mais pour ce qui est
des hominidés ils n'ont jamais trouvé
qu'un seul bras droit qu une seule jambe
gauche et qu'un seul bassin à dire que
si on avait trouvé de jambe gauche ou
bien de bras droit d'un forcément on se
serait dit à l'ats il ya plusieurs
squelettes mais il n'y avait aucun
doublon dans la collection dos
d'hominidés qu'ils avaient donc ils se
sont dit que forcément il n'y avait
qu'un seul individu
oui mais à l'époque il n'avait pas
envisagé que des fragments de babouins
puisse se glisser dans la collection
or étant donné la méthode de fouilles
sachant qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé le
squelette tout entier au même endroit
mais qu'ils ont glané les fragments de
ce squelette alentours avant de trouver
où se trouvait la source de tous et au
la possibilité d'une contamination du
squelette est plus que probable d'une
contamination du squelette par d'autres
fossiles d'autres individus d'hominidés
voire même d'autres espèces si elles
n'ont pas été identifié correctement et
c'est ce qui est arrivé avec sept
vertèbres l'une des vertèbres de lucie
n'était en fait pas de l'hominidé mais
appartenait un babouin se bat bras et va
certainement contaminés le fossile de à
l 280 8-1 lors de cette phase de
ramassage en surface ou peut-être même
lors de la collecte sachant que les os
du squelette de lucy n'étaient pas
connectés les uns aux autres alors du
coup qu'est ce que cela implique pour le
squelette de lucy et bien ça implique
tout simplement que ce squelette
n'appartient pas à un seul individu
il appartient au moins à deux individus
un australopithèque et abat bois donc en
plus deux individus d'espèces
différentes
et sachant que la méthode de collecte
n'exclut pas qu'il y ait eu plus de
contamination que ça eh bien on se
retrouve avec un gros problème celui de
la possibilité que l'uci ne soit en fait
qu'un squelette composite fait de
plusieurs individus voire même de
plusieurs individus de plusieurs espèces
le squelette de lucy n'existerait même
pas et la possibilité que lucie n'existe
pas en tant qu'individu unique et bien
ça remet pas mal de choses en question
et notamment la validité de l'espèce
qu'on a créé à partir de ce squelette
australopithecus afarensis puisque l'uci
était le premier
simen décrit de l'espèce
australopithecus afarensis et bien ça ça
doit vouloir dire que tous les morceaux
d'australopithecus afarensis qui ont été
trouvés après lucy et qui ont été
comparés à l'uci et dont on a dit bon
ben ok ça ça ressemble à lui si donc ces
australopithecus afarensis regarder ce
fémur c'est certainement
australopithecus afarensis puisqu'il est
identique à celui de lucie tous ces
fragments là si ça se trouve c'est pas
de l'australopithecus afarensis alors ça
ne veut pas forcément dire que ces
touches du babouin évidemment mais ça
doit vouloir dire qu'il y à une ou
plusieurs espèces dans ce qu'on appelle
australopithecus afarensis peut-être
d'autres espèces d'hominidés peut-être
même d'autres espèces de primates qui
sont très difficiles à distinguer de
l'hominidé pour résumer les implications
de cette découverte
simplement la découverte de sept
vertèbres de babouins à l'intérieur du
squelette de lucy
mais caduque l'espèce australopithecus
afarensis comment les scientifiques ont
ils pu être dupées si longtemps autour
de 40 ans et se faire servir un fragment
de vertèbre de babouins pour de
l'australopithèque sans jamais s'en
rendre compte comment après qu'une
génération entière de chercheurs est
observée ce spécimen sous toutes les
coutures
ne s'étant pas rendu compte qu'il y
traîner peut-être du babouin
y aurait-il eu dissimulation les esprits
les plus sceptiques d'entre vous pourrez
peut-être même se demander pourquoi les
scientifiques
pourrait-il cacher la vérité aurait ton
volontairement fermé les yeux et
pieusement menti par omission pour
couvrir cette erreur ou peut-être la
tonte fait pour défendre la théorie de
l'évolution
à mon avis il ya une réponse qui est
beaucoup plus simple la réalité c'est
que si tout le monde croit avoir vu un
squelette de lucy
par exemple dans les musées dans des
expositions à la télévision est bien en
réalité il n'ya qu'une poignée de
privilégiés qui ont eu accès au matériel
original tout ce que vous avez pu voir à
la télé dans les expositions dans les
musées
ce sont des moulages de lucie des copie
conforme de l'original moulé directement
sur l'original mais ça ne reste que des
copies l'original lui il est enfermé
dans un coffre fort à addis abeba en
ethiopie et il n'en sort quasiment
jamais alors pourquoi ils sont enfermés
dans un coffre-fort à addis ababa déjà
parce que c'est le set en ethiopie qu'on
l'a découvert donc il est normal que le
fossile reste à addis ababa donc je sais
bien qu'on n'a pas tous les jours
l'occasion d'aller à addis ababa smm
justement pour ça qu'on fait des copies
de l'original c'est pour pouvoir les
envoyer à travers le monde pour que
justement tout le monde n'est pas
mir en ethiopie pour venir voir le
fossile autant avoir une copie à la
maison et puis aussi bas c'est pour
ménager le spécimen puisque les
manipulations excessive même par les
chercheurs aussi précautionneux soit ils
finissent toujours par endommager un
petit peu les fossiles donc autant
travaillé sur une copie conforme que sur
le spécimen original puisque on risque
de détériorer le spécimen originale en
travaillant directement dessus donc bas
pendant 40 ans la plupart des chercheurs
se sont contentés de travailler sur des
moulages
or ce qui a permis aux chercheurs de la
publication du 6 juin 2015 de se rendre
compte que sept vertèbres n'avait rien à
voir avec le reste du squelette c'est sa
texture est là une patine qui est
légèrement plus polie que celle des
autres
zoé qui montre que sept vertèbres a subi
des conditions de fossilisation
légèrement différente sans même dire que
c'est du babouin ou autre chose
et bah ça ça va vouloir dire que sept
vertèbres elle a connu une autre
histoire que le reste du squelette ça
veut dire que sept vertèbres
elle vient d'ailleurs et ça les moulages
n'en rendent pas du tout content puisque
le moulage ne rend pas compte de la
texture et de la couleur des eaux
autre raison pour laquelle personne
n'avait vu ça avant 2015
et bien c'est tout simplement parce que
très peu de gens s'intéressent aux
vertèbres faut bien voir que jamais
aucune grande théorie n'a été construite
sur l'évolution des hominidés juste à
partir de la forme des vertèbres de
l'uci et surtout pas à partir de la
forme de sept vertèbres là qui est juste
un petit arc neural isolé n'y a pas
énormément d'informations à tirer d'un
arc neural isolé comme sept vertèbres
qu'on a attribué à du babouin
à l'intérieur de ce spécimen à elle de
180 8-1
donc ça aussi ça explique pourquoi on
n'a pas vu qu'il y avait un contaminant
à l'intérieur du squelette de lucy et
maintenant qu'on a découvert qu'il y
avait au moins un contaminant à
l'intérieur du squelette bien cela remet
tout en question tout l'intégrité du
squelette est remise en question si ça
se trouve il ya aussi des fragments de
côte qui viennent d'autres spécimens
voyez tous ces eaux dont on ne sait pas
trop quoi faire
peut-être appartiennent t-il eu aussi à
d'autres spécimens à d'autres
représentants soient des
australopithèques soit d'autres primates
donc à partir de là on comme on ne peut
pas être sur la prudence veut que lucie
tombe caduque
alors évidemment lui si c'est un phare
de la théorie de l'évolution des
hominidés
c'est la figure de proue de l'évolution
des amis
d et à chaque fois qu'on parle
d'évolution des hominidés on montre le
squelette de lucy
alors du coup si le squelette de lucy
n'est pas qu'un seul squelette et voire
même n'est pas fait que d'une seule
espèce
on pourrait être tenté de dire que ça
remet tout la théorie de l'évolution des
hominidés en question et ça semblerait
légitime
et bien la réponse est non non déjà
parce qu'il faut tempérer les
conclusions de cette étude
ils ont regardé le squelette de lucy ont
découvert qu une vertèbre ne collait pas
avec le reste ils y ont aussi découvert
que tout le reste allait bien ensemble
donc a priori il n'y a pas de raison de
considérer que tout le reste du
squelette n'appartiennent pas un seul
individu
oui mais principe de précaution oblige
il faut de toute façon considéré que
l'uci est un spécimen qui a besoin
d'être révisée totalement et que
l'australopithecus afarensis doit être
révisée totalement mais de toute façon
même si on considère que
australopithecus afarensis n'existe plus
n'a plus d'existence
il faut voir que australopithecus
afarensis ce n'est qu'une espèce parmi
tant d'autres il ya des dizaines d'
espèce d'hominidé fossiles et on en
découvre de nouvelles chaque année de
nouvelles espèces d'australopithèques en
particulier sont décrites chaque année
donc en réalité ça plus fait effet
pétard mouillé que coup de tonnerre dont
l'étude a été publiée dans le journal of
human evolution journal of human
evolution est un grand journal de
paléoanthropologie mais ça reste un
journal classique de paléoanthropologie
pour parler d'un coup de tonnerre il y
aurait fallu que cette étude sont
publiés dans une revue
multidisciplinaire a trait au facteur
d'impact comme nature's hussain donc
déjà parlé de coup de tonnerre c'est
quand même pas mal exagérer si on
récapitule un petit peu l'histoire de
lucy lucy hale a été découverte dans les
années 70 et dans les années soixante
dix ça a été
l'hominidé le plus ancien jamais
découvert yutz et trois millions
d'années
l'uci s'est posée comme le premier
représentant de notre lignée or depuis
on a fait beaucoup de découvertes et la
racine évolutif du genre humain a
énormément reculé l'âge du plus ancien
fossile a plus que doublé
aujourd'hui avec toumaï on parle de 7
millions d'années ou bien se rendre
compte que les progrès ont été immenses
depuis la découverte de lucy est que
l'uci si elle a encore une place et on
va dire iconique dans l'arbre évolutif
humain cette icône isation elle est
purement symbolique et l'espèce qu'elle
représente australopithecus afarensis
n'est qu'une espèce parmi énormément
d'autres espèces donc même si on part du
prince
que la présence de sept vertèbres de
babouins appelle au principe de
précaution est donc à la validation du
spécimen à elle de 180 8-1 comme
n'appartenant qu'à un seul individu est
donc sachant que ce spécimen donc l'uci
a été le premier spécimen trouver
d'australopithecus afarensis et sert
donc de spécimens référence ayant servi
pour l'attribution d'autres fossiles à
l'espèce australopithecus afarensis donc
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
chaque fois qu'on ramasse et un morceau
d'os dont la comparer à l'uci puis on
s'est dit bah ça ça ressemble à lui si
donc ces australopithecus afarensis ça
ça me ressemble pas c'est une autre
espèce donc même en partant du principe
que australopithecus afarensis n'existe
plus n'a plus de valeur scientifique et
que par prudence on décide de ne plus
considérer australopithecus afarensis
comme une espèce valide et bien même en
considérant tout ça de toute façon on ne
fait mourir qu'une seule petite branche
qu'une seule petite ramifications
surtout l'arbre évolutif humain une
seule petite branche
il y en ad vingtaine donc il faut pas
croire que tu es cette seule branche va
faire mourir tout l'arbre aucunement
jamais de la vie que l'espèce
australopithecus afarensis soit valide
ou non ça ne change rien au schéma
général de l'évolution humaine
le schéma général de l'évolution humaine
il existe déjà depuis très longtemps
déjà dans les années 70 le schéma
général de l'évolution humaine était
établi à l'époque de lui si on avait
déjà découvert l'homme de néandertal
homo erectus et même les
australopithèques existait déjà parce
que l'uci n'est pas le premier
représentant découvert
d'australopithèques loin s'en faut le
premier représentant d'australopithèques
c'est l'enfant de tongs qui a été
découvert en 1925 et il a été accompagné
quelques années après avec un nouveau
crâne celui de mi6 play ce qui a été
découvert peu de temps après tout ça en
afrique du sud
alors l'enfant de tongs mis six pièces
sont plus jeunes que lui si oui mais le
genre australopithèques lui existait
bien avant lui si donc le schéma général
de l'évolution humaine
il existait déjà bien avant donc
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya eu cet effet de
pétard mouillé plutôt que de coups de
tonnerre dans la communauté scientifique
à l'annoncé de cette découverte est bas
ce n'est pas seulement un silence gêné
du fait du caractère incommodant de
cette découverte pour les
paléoanthropologues c'est aussi parce
que bas les implications de cette
découverte sont pas non plus gigantesque
n'y a pas de grosse remise en question
de
le schéma évolutif humain juste parce
que l'uci n'est plus un spécimen valide
ok c'est une icône qui tombe c'est une
statue qui s'effondre mais c'est tout
c'est un symbole qui tombe il n'ya que
voilà il n'ya qu'un symbole qui tombe à
mon avis ce qu'il est plus prudent de
faire c'est d'arrêter de parler de lui
si il faut arrêter de parler de lui si
comme étant un seul et unique individu
en tout cas tant qu' une grande révision
de cette espèce qui s'appelle
australopithecus afarensis n'a pas eu
lieu tant que quelqu'un a pas repris
tous les morceaux connus
d'australopithecus afarensis et valider
ce qui était bien de l'australopithecus
afarensis et ceux qui n'en étaient pas
ou bien recréer une nouvelle espèce à
partir de tout ça qui serait épuré de
toute contamination éventuelle voilà en
attendant que cet énorme effort qui
naquit ne viendra probablement pas de
sitôt se produise eh bien il faudrait ne
plus parler de lui si et remplacé lucie
par quelque chose d'autre part une autre
espèce d'australopithèque alors je sais
que les habitudes ont la vie dure et je
pense que ce sera pas pour demain que
l'on verra dans les médias des gens
arrêter de se précipiter sur lucie dès
qu'on parle d'australopithèques ou
d'évolution humaine mais voici au moins
quelques suggestions pour vous si vous
êtes enseignant si vous êtes journaliste
pourquoi pas donc voilà si vous voulez
faire une présentation demain sur
l'évolution des humains mais que vous
voulez rester prudent quant au cas de
lucie et bien voici quelques suggestions
pour la remplacer et la suggestion qui à
mon avis est la meilleure c'est d'en
revenir aux sources d'australopithèques
et la source d'australopithèques le
premier individu qui a été découvert
d'australopithèques c'est l'enfant de
tang l'enfant de tongs c'est le premier
spécimen qui a été nommé
australopithecus avec lui vous ne pouvez
pas vous tromper quoi qu'il arrive avec
les australopithèques dans le futur de
la classification des espèces
appartenant à l'arbre évolutif de
l'homme l'enfant de tang sera toujours
appelé australopithecus africanus parce
que c'est lui le type du genre
australopithèque et de l'espèce
africanus mais le truc c'est qu'on n'a
pas de squelettes entiers
c'est vrai que l' avantage de l'uci sait
que c'était aussi le premier squelette
attribué à un seul spécimen qui était
aussi complet si ce que vous souhaitez
avoir donc c'est un squelette entier
d'australopithèques il y a le tout
récemment décrit australopithèques us
diba qui va pouvoir vous aider vous
aurez même un squelette entier et un
squelette en bonus car il ya deux
squelettes quasiment complet qui ont été
découverts beaucoup plus complet que ne
l'a jamais été l'uci après le problème
ces constats le pit et cus sediba c'est
une espèce qui est très dérivés
d'australopithèques tellement dérivés
qu'il se pourrait même qu'il s'agisse en
fait d'un homo célibat australopithecus
prometheus plus connu sous le nom de
little foot petit pied en français elle
australopithèques us qu'il vous faut si
vous voulez être sûr d'avoir un
australopithèque entier little foot
c'est le spécimen d'australopithèques
découvert le plus complet jamais trouvé
il ne manque quasiment rien le problème
c'est qu'il est impossible de trouver
une image du squelette de little foot
monter parce que le squelette de little
foot n'a pas encore été totalement
décrit little foot on en a décrit le
pied le squelette a été vite fait décrit
dans un article paru dans une revue sud
africaine qui est introuvable et surtout
le squelette de little foot n'a jamais
été montée parce que je ne suis même pas
sûr qu'ils aient fini de le nettoyer
donc très prochainement peut-être nous
aurons accès à des photos
d'australopithecus prometheus
donc voilà trois options pour remplacer
l'uci si vous souhaitez parler
d'australopithèques chacun a ses petits
inconvénients
évidemment si c'était si facile de
trouver des squelettes entiers où serait
le plaisir de fouiller
donc pour conclure cette vidéo et bien
je vais répondre à la question que j'ai
posée tout au début nous aurait-on menti
lucie serait-elle un babouin alors déjà
question en deux parties lucie serait à
la barre - vous aurez compris que non
l'uci n'est pas abba bois il ya un
morceau de babouins à l'intérieur mais
ça ne fait pas de tout le squelette
celui d'un babouin le reste du squelette
appartient bien à de l'hominidé les
auteurs de l'article disent qu'il s'agit
bien d'un seul spécimen ou en tout cas
que leurs observations ne permettent pas
de conclure que le reste du squelette
n'appartient pas à un seul spécimen donc
le reste du squelette il peut être
considéré comme appartenant à deux lots
mini des donc sur tous les partis qui
ont été très étudiée comme le bassin le
fémur les dents ça ça a été vu revu sur
étudié sur répéter on peut être certain
qu'ils appartiennent à deux
une idée maintenant si on veut être
réellement prudent et bien il faut
considérer que l'uci n'est pas fait
damer de plusieurs individus mais en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
tout n'est pas du babouin dans l'ue
singh il n'y a qu'un petit bout de
babouins avérés et c'est tout deuxième
partie de la question qui est en fait la
première
nous aurait-on menti non on ne nous a
pas menti il n'y a pas eu de
cachotteries de la part des
scientifiques
d'une part parce que le fait de
découvrir que l'uci n'est pas un seul et
unique spécimen est le fait de découvrir
que australopithecus afarensis n'est pas
une espèce valides ne change rien à la
théorie de l'évolution donc ya pas de
raison de faire de cachotteries pour
essayer de préserver le grand schéma
évolutif
les fossiles ne sont qu'une partie du
grand schéma évolutif de l'évolution de
l'homme l'évolution humaine
elle a été un ferrer avant même de
découvrir des fossiles et plus récemment
l'adn est venue se rajouter à ça de
grandes similitudes de l'adn existe
entre l'homme et le chimpanzé plus qu'il
n'en existe entre le chimpanzé et le
gorille voilà le grand schéma évolutif
humain il n'est pas fait que de faux
cils torpiller un fossile n'y changera
rien de toute façon le point le plus
important c'est qui a pas eu
cachotteries la découverte elle a été
publié 6 juin 2015 journal of human
evolution c'est un article écrit par des
paléoanthropologues des évolutionnistes
kivu dix sept vertèbres n'est pas d'une
vertèbre d'australopithèques il y as
contamination dans le squelette de lucy
ce sont bien des paléoanthropologues
qu'ils nous le disent
donc ya pas cachotteries sur ce coup là
il faut bien se mettre à la place de ces
chercheurs qui sont allés voir le
squelette de lucy qui sont allés
l'étudier à fond et qui pointe du doigt
leurs erreurs et par ailleurs il faut
aussi saluer la remarquable acceptation
de la communauté palais anthropologique
qui constatant cette erreur n'a pas
empêché cet article d'être publié et le
même vous dire que quelques mois plus
tôt il avait été présentée à un congrès
et personnes la sortie de fusil pour
flinguer les chercheurs qui ont fait
cette découverte la découverte de la
vertèbre de babouins dans le squelette
de lucy elle a été présentée en congrès
elle a été présentée au public à travers
un article qui a été lui-même relu par
des experts pour validation avant sa
publication et que le processus a
fonctionné et que le processus de
révision de l'opinion scientifique a
complètement fonctionné du début à la
fin
donc voilà même si on marche sur les
plates-bandes des géants même si c'est
pas très sexy en tant que chercheur de
s'intéresser à des parties du squelette
comme la colle
vertébrale qui suscite généralement peu
d'intérêt cet article a été quand même
publié là où les créationnistes et les
sceptiques de l'évolution en général
seraient enclins à penser que c'est une
défaite de l'évolution que l'on vient de
perdre un de nos emblèmes une de nos
icônes concernant l'évolution des
espèces bah c'est ces gens là il faut
bien leur faire comprendre qu'il ya pas
d'icône en évolution des est spécial les
médias peuvent iconiser ces espèces
s'ils veulent les médias peuvent
iconiser lucie autant qu'ils veulent ils
peuvent continuer à iconiser lucie s'ils
le veulent mais celui-ci n'est pas plus
iconiques que n'importe quel autre
espèce d'hominidé fossile donc voir
lucie tomber n'est absolument pas une
défaite est au contraire c'est une
victoire pour la paléoanthropologie
puisque on a réussi à se débarrasser de
ce petit fragment de vertèbre qui ne
parasite est le signal ou qui auraient
pu le parasite et à l'avenir si l'une
des espèces de l'arbre évolutif de
l'homme n'est plus valide il faut le
savoir pour pouvoir corriger cet arbre
et pour pouvoir obtenir une image plus
nette de ce qu est l évolution humaine
donc on a bien on a bien progressé dans
notre connaissance de l'évolution
humaine
grâce à cette découverte on n'a pas
régressé donc non non ce n'est pas une
défaite c'est une victoire qui nous
rappelle que la pratique de la
paléontologie comme celle de n'importe
quelle science ne se fait pas dans le
dogme et la croyance aveugle la
paléontologie ne se pratique pas dans la
croyance que l'uci est plus importante
que toumaï ne se fait pas dans la
croyance que l'uci est un spécimen qui a
toute son intégrité alors qu'il ne l'a
pas et que maintenant on le sait donc
voilà on va pas continuer à croire
aveuglément à ce qu'on a envie de croire
non on peut croire que la réfutabilité
est une faiblesse en réalité c'est une
force c'est parce qu'on arrive à
détruire ses murs qu'on construit qu'on
peut aller au delà de ces murs cet
article est un exemple de la
transparence dans laquelle la théorie de
l'évolution se construit elle nous
montre comment les sciences de
l'évolution progresse dans la douleur de
la réfutabilité en sciences c'est en se
tirant des balles dans le pied qu'on
avance parce qu'il n'y a que comme ça
qu'on peut savoir si on est capable de
l'esquivé ou non c'est en tirant à bout
portant dans notre théorie au boulet de
canon qu'on arrive à savoir si notre mur
y tient debout et quand il s'effondre
c'est humiliant c'est désagréable mais
c'est comme ça qu'on avance
la science c'est comme ça qu'elle
devrait aller elle devrait aller au delà
du sentiment personnel donc découvrir
sept vertèbres de babouins à l'intérieur
du squelette de lucy
ça a été certes un petit pas en arrière
pour le paléoanthropologue mais par
contre ça a été un très grand pas en
avant
la paléontologie en général